also die sie waren selbst reichlich und
wir müssen die sachen branchen also die
gerade unser sagen sind deckt aber sie
hat so eine seltene schlangen gehabt und
sie hat den ganzen film gepackt nach
eines durch und jeder gesagt
später dann wir ich dir später genau an
das hat sie gefragt und dann auf einmal
gab jemand ein stück ja gar nicht nach
china japan und gesagt ey alter du du
brauchst noch eine jacke die ist
bestimmt weil das eine so eine jacke
thema und so nicht so einem banner pulli
und daher eine deponie geholt und dann
aber am album hat es auch gesehen und
dann ist das ungerecht oder ja dann
unglaublich wenn bei mir kalt ist warum
man eine jacke für mich wenn ich schon
hundertmal nachgefragt habe und dann hat
sie zu der eric gesagt du bist schön
weil ich kann ja für gekriegt habe und
wäre hätte er nach einer jacke für mich
aber das wäre bestimmt nicht gewusst
dass du sehr kalt war
doch das hat denn alle gewusst